You're welcome at the glass house.
Drink.
I spooned name,
uh,
hot time Bush or seven full time from when I was 12.
What the vote mean to you?
I can't see.
I told women power is in your hat on one case.
Some of us do cake off
my life.
I've been respectful.
Dumb what men told me,
wife,
my wife.
That's what you're meant to be.
But I can't have that anymore.
Never underestimate the power.
We women have to define our own destiny.
Five,
this stuff
we should copy into the hall of Communications.
My job is 24.
No means nothing to me off.
I must say.
You're making the law.
We have reached a state of anarchy.
We can no longer tolerate those responsible and whatever.
Where you can,
we'll stop you.
What are you going to do?
Lockers it were up.
We were in every,
oh,
we're off the human race.
You can't stop as all,
we do not want to door.
They test.
We want to build on it.
It does.
Yeah.
The waves forward.
No more,
no less than you would be willing.
Never,
never give up the fight.
Good evening.
Um,
I'm absolutely delighted to welcome you here and not least because you're about
to see a film,
which I absolutely loved.
And by the end you will be extremely angry with Switzerland.
Just look out for that.
And not least because it's such a groundbreaking film in so many ways.
And we're very lucky to have a female director and a female writer at 94% of
films in Hollywood are directed by men.
75% of leading roles go to men.
So having a film that focuses on female experiences I think is,
is really overdue and reading.
It's been a passion project for a decade for solar and wind done Britt land
together.
And so when she came to about six years ago,
like probably most people,
I was thinking it's big hats and,
and courses.
So I didn't,
I wasn't really terribly interested if I'm honest.
And so when I sat down and looked through an incredible body of research that
Sarah had already built on,
which we built on during the course of,
um,
the writing and then into production and beyond.
And we actually set up a website where we can download all of this information
by the end so that collectively we could all kind of draw from it.
Um,
it,
it was really extraordinary and I,
you know,
I took a wrong steer the first time I wrote it and it was only two.
I really went back and looked at the testimonials of the working women that they
felt very contemporary and very vivid and really genuinely shocking.
Yeah.
So when you talk about that,
it's about the idea that instead of following,
you know,
Mrs Pancoast,
one of the iconic characters or even following a high profile,
you know,
so there's princess of fear is another example or one of the,
the middle class women who you might find,
you know,
has their own Wikipedia page.
You're trying to look for somebody who wouldn't have ever made it to Wikipedia.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think the class,
she was really big for us and the fact that there were so many women who were
absolutely instrumental in the organization and in the kind of hierarchy of the
suffragette movement and they had huge sacrifices placed on their lives.
But ultimately if they were incarcerated,
they could either pay bail to get out or it didn't really matter if they had a
week away because they didn't,
they weren't dependent on jobs or that income was for the working woman.
It was,
it was,
it was devastating to her life if she was incarcerated for even a few days cause
she could lose her job.
So I think that was what we really wanted to do.
And also,
you know,
those photographs you talk about,
we saw some really amazing photos of these laundries in east London and everyone
looked impeccably clean and beautiful black aprons and white starch shirts.
And it was only one you broke down and started to read the incredible list of
diseases and not disease,
sorry,
infections and injuries and conditions that came out of working in this place.
And you want to say actually they had an incredibly short shelf life.
Um,
I,
you read as a kind of lie going on about how you represent that era.
It's always a big question.
When it comes to the feminist movement,
how much do you try and play down intro,
feminist conflicts?
Um,
so we know in the suffragettes for example,
that Mrs Pancreas,
but it was one of our own daughters over who got the vote when you were rising
it Abby,
how much did you think,
how much drama am I going to put in between the women themselves as well as
their fight outwards?
Um,
I think in a way it was,
I mean,
most I think most good,
um,
writings about what you leave out,
you know,
so it's just basically you're constantly stripping back and stripping back as
much as she can.
And so,
you know,
it's,
the old adage is take out every third line.
And so I think the,
you know,
you always wanted to make those relationships feel authentic and of the now.
Um,
so I guess that's what I focused on than anything,
was to try and make it feel like it had sort of contemporary resonance.
I mean,
there was a,
there was an amazing drum you could have done about Emily and Pancoast.
There's an amazing drummer you can do by 71,
Davidson.
But in a way,
it's all about putting,
um,
the kind of political and the personal for me.
And the big change is actually happening in the most undramatic moments.
But those are where the real drama moments happen.
And it's very weird because you haven't seen it yet.
So I don't want to give too much away.
But,
um,
and so it was always about using history to kind of act as this wonderful gal
point of resistance and this kind of beautiful visual sort of touchstones
throughout the film.
But it was always reflecting back to these,
ironically,
these kinds of fictional characters lives who are kind of carry the authentic
truth of,
of a woman moving effectively from a passive place to medicine activism.
So that was always the focus really.
Well,
I think the schisms in the movement because they were schism.
But you know,
if you look at any political movement,
never schisms at the top.
And in a way had we focused on them,
it would have been an examination of firstly the exceptional women,
the painkillers and also an examination of power and what it does.
And I think what was more interesting and more engaging with the admiral or
connected with the contemporary world was to look at,
um,
the ordinary women,
the women with no platform,
no document in her journey towards activism.
And what we forget because we get received so much about the schism is the
comradery and the unifying things.
And you know,
in a way I think that was kind of more interesting to bring that out there is
friction,
but I think to look at that is interesting.
And how important to you was it that it was an ensemble piece?
Because one of the things,
you know,
the very famous test about the Bechdel test of,
of women in cinema is not just,
Oh,
you know,
all them is no more than one woman in it.
Um,
you know,
do they have names?
Do they talk about something other than a man?
Actually representing the relationships between women is one of the prompts.
We keep arms even in a film we have a female protagonist.
She's often a hunger games example surrounded by men.
Yeah.
So was that something that was a conscious decision on your part?
Yeah,
I think it was very exciting,
the idea of looking at the relationship between women and as Abby said before,
but the idea you so rare that you have in one film,
Carey Mulligan,
Anne Marie Duff had an a bottom Carter or having proper roles,
a little role for Meryl Streep and Romola Guy.
Right.
You know,
to see all those women working together and there was on set this very unusual.
So I'm fucked.
I can stop them laughing the whole time.
It just sort of break them up to get shot.
But,
but um,
there was this great sense of comradery.
Yeah.
And I think it's also an economic thing.
You know,
you're,
you know,
if women don't get those roads and don't get the ensemble films beyond making
people laugh or the romantic wrong Kong,
then you won't ever be able to prove yourself in the box office and the
algorithm was won't work and no one will give you the money to make those
movies.
So part of the journey to actually going,
no,
I want three lead actresses in this foam and then slowly it and I want them all
to get paid the same as if it was a man is actually,
and then it sells as well.
Then you start to change the model and people start going,
okay,
we might do another film that might be about the female fighter pilot pilots,
which of which there were a fantastic group and the second world war that have
never been written about,
for example.
So this is the important point for all the audience is.
But if you like films like this,
you have to go out and encourage everyone you've ever met to go out and see it
because that's the only way that you will get more.
Yeah.
To reverse the trend and I think,
you know,
there is an appetite for female centered films but we need to work hard to prove
it.
I mean it was an interesting thing on this film that when we were casting the
male roles they were harder because the agents kept on ringing up and saying can
they be a bit bigger,
the male roles.
So you know,
it's a kind of inverse of what
can we getting a fight scene or kind of Ben Whishaw was characters ziplining
down through the laundry or something to beef it up.
A bit of beef it up.
Um,
one which note I show.
The one thing I did want to ask you was that there's been a lot of discussion
really about recasting traditionally male roles.
You know,
this idea of Gina Davis has of just going through your script and just changing
a couple of the male characters names to female characters,
not even necessarily changing all that much else.
Can you think of a film or character you'd love to see rebooted,
which kind to see a female Scarface or
I'd love to see Goodfellas.
I'd really like to take good photos.
I'd love women to be able to be violent.
I'd love them to be able to be sexual.
I'd love them to be able to be inappropriate.
I'd love them to be able to be aggressive.
And I'd love men to be able to be soft and magnolia steel.
Magnolias no,
I mean,
you know,
I,
I'd love to,
I'd let you know,
I love,
I'm a,
my,
I'm love Scorsese firms.
I mean,
I love them and I want women to be able to be as flawed.
I want them to rail.
It was flawed as they are in life.
You know,
we've written about a group of heroes,
but you know,
this is another on other ways.
And I think people can be flawed.
Women can be flawed and heroes.
And that's why I tried to do
the other thing.
I read something that you said a Abbey,
which was that you'd find emoney widen Davidson's perse.
So you'd seen it during the course of filming and there's been a huge debate
about whether or not she meant to kill herself by throwing himself under the
horse.
It's,
um,
it's often referenced the fact she had a return ticket.
But the thing you mentioned was the fact that she had a postage stamp,
which women often use to let people know that they were in,
in prison.
Are there any other details like that that you've managed to bring into the film
that people should look out for when they're watching it?
Oh,
that's a really lovely story of the m scarf.
Well,
the thing about the return ticket by the way,
is the everybody had to return ticket that day.
So,
um,
cause they sold them as return ticket.
So I'm not sure that tells you that she thought she was going to get back.
And also as a woman who was going to do a protest,
she know I actually want to be arrested for that protest.
So I don't think she ever thought she was going to get a train back from that.
Whatever happened.
Yeah.
Um,
but,
and it's so interesting doing a historical film,
cause I could literally,
I've now spoken to probably 30 historians,
but I could find someone who argued every which way on every single point.
You realize there's no single version of history.
So if anyone says it's inaccurate though,
but I'll be wrong.
But what was the other bit,
the bit about,
I know I take the point in this program,
I hope not going dish at the back of one of the things.
I know that there's this lovely story,
but it's slightly blends the end the and turn it off.
Yeah.
So there I went in there.
Okay.
We sort of blend Andrew anyway,
but they didn't know about the robot.
No,
that's fine.
I think anything is when you watch it.
One of the things I think that it still shocks men stays with me as the emoney
Walden Davidson was forced fed 49 times and actually just to be force fed once
is very,
very dangerous.
So forcemain times wait,
so kind of,
yeah,
I think that's one of the most shocking moments in the film.
I mean there are a lot of,
as you see parallels with,
with what's happening contemporarily now,
but both the idea of how somebody is radicalized and what that means for their
life and also what kind of extra judicial confinement means.
And what states do,
what violence they inflict on people that they want to suppress.
I thought that was,
yeah,
you certainly don't flinch in the force feeding scenes from the,
I mean there is I think a very strong Amoco of rape and what's happening in
those scenes and then the women did talk about it.
They tend to violation.
Absolutely.
On that note,
probably I like to take a couple of questions from the room.
We've got some microphones.
If you would like to put your hands up.
Can I have a Mike over here
that just wanted to know whether there was why now and you must have researched,
but there have been other attempts to write this book and turn it into a movie.
What,
what do you think was the reason that this thousand lines now and this happened
in 2015 only when would you actually as a,
as a story to tell table because I was surprised to hear nobody ever,
it's such an opposite material and for so long has been ignored.
Well,
I think it's a symptom of inequality.
It's,
you know,
in a way you were the academics who consulted on this project.
So we're not surprised it hasn't been made.
It took ages to get this story into the academy,
wasn't on the school curriculum for years.
Women's history is marginalized even though it was an incredible movement and it
spanned over 50 years and involved on thousands actually of women and was the
biggest movement,
political movement of it's t at the time.
Um,
it has been kind of in some ways buried.
And I also think in terms of why it hasn't got to the big screen,
is it also because you know,
as,
as Helen mentioned at the beginning,
there's a paltry amount of women in film.
Unfortunately,
I'm very hopeful it's going to change,
but there's one to 10%.
I mean this year at the London film festival,
against the odds,
there's 46 films directed by women,
but that's still 20% of the festival,
which is great because it defies the odds of 1% to 10% of films directed by
women.
But we're still in a situation where you don't have many women's stories are
women behind the camera.
And my final question to wrap up,
really as we're sitting in a room full of incredibly young,
energetic tech savvy women and men,
what can they do to help women in film and to help the feminist fight more
generally?
Well,
I mean,
I would just to say I think another reason why I think,
I think it's the digital age actually.
I think the fact that we are so globally connected with,
um,
uh,
stories of inequality that were flat back on our own,
you know,
two to three women are killed by a partner or ex partner every,
every weekend,
the UK.
And we see that globally and,
and so I think it makes us self reflect.
I think it's,
you know,
I think it's allowing the discourse to happen in a,
in a democratic way.
So even the bad and as one as the good needs to be online.
So that's really exciting.
I think it's just telling everybody to go and see it.
Please.
It's a really,
genuinely,
it's a little,
I think we're curious.
We're curious to see if it is going to make it in the box office or next week
we'll be weeping into our champagne glass.
It's very tough.
We're really on the front of Vermin too,
but,
um,
yeah,
we just,
it would,
I mean,
genuinely we just need to prove it.
I think that's a brilliant moment to wrap up and I hope everyone give a really
big round of applause to you.
[inaudible].